so um memeology put this uh put this
video together
shout out to memeology good dude uh
youtube is now giving
community strikes for playlists
youtube is not a community strike
guidelines for playlist
[Music]
and then it's a tweet here from uh
sheila a
aliens alert youtube is now issuing
community guidelines strikes and
warnings for playlists that's right
a list uh com uh a list i compiled of
other videos that aren't even mine has
now gotten me in trouble on youtube
this is [ __ ] absolutely right you
could get in trouble you really just
want to get all the strikes out of the
way so they can start punishing people
again
so you could get in trouble by proxy
even for the stuff that isn't your
content
that's pretty [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
and it says clearly right there yeah
yeah type playlist playlist
how can they give you a strike for
something that you didn't
make you put something together right
yeah i mean i would only say
if like okay the only time just trying
to play a devil's advocate here
the only time i say maybe it would be
okay is let's say you posted like a
bunch of crazy violent [ __ ]
on a like on day wave live
to try to evade a band but then usually
the rotc or day wave
radio to like make the playlist and they
could determine that you're both guy
dad i might have that chat i might have
that conversation yes
but this is just people going like oh i
like that video let me add that to my
playlist
that's pretty funny getting pop for
playlist and does that mean like
even private plan how do you even report
i don't know how do you report is there
a report function on the playlist
it has to be i mean there has to be
and i bet you if you do read in the
community guidelines it's very vague
about what they could ban you for and
probably one of the things that was
probably just updated recently in the
community guidelines is they can hit you
for playlists
uh youtube playlist what the [ __ ] was
wtf was removed because it violates
community guidelines
because it's the first uh because it's
the first time this is just a warning
if it happens again your channel will
get a strike and you won't be able to do
anything
like upload or post live streams for a
week uh a second strike
we all know so this is for a playlist
and yes they're
now giving warnings and by the way you
don't get we don't get retroactive
warnings
like revenge of the sisters around
before they gave warnings and we've
already received strikes
so if we do something again we don't get
a warning like we eat
warning is only for new people are you
serious yeah so like here's how it is
it's not fair
this is like getting [ __ ] on the uh
new customers sign up get a 30
rebate like i've been here for two years
i don't get a rebate yeah
but think about that for a second that
that we we've been
two two community strikes we've gotten
and we've gotten the copyright strike
and whatever
uh we we wouldn't get
the the courtesy even though everybody
else now gets to courtesy because we've
already been hit with a strike
so we should know better
uh we want to help us at youtube so
please make sure you understand your
community guidelines and strikes
review your contact we know this it
expires in 90 days
i don't remember how long i made the
playlist but it was very old but i think
it was a playlist full of those
disturbing videos of children that
youtube didn't do anything about
for and i was flagging them and adding
them to a playlist to track the ones i
had flagged
oh okay yeah so this yes that was
probably during elsa gate
well uh yeah very old but yeah it's very
old you're right it probably
i was doing stuff and she was probably
doing it and probably telling
other people hey check out this playlist
i made if you want to easily be able to
report a bunch of them
exactly you know what i mean exactly so
god forbid you know again no good deed
goes unpunished
you're right she was doing the right
thing yeah you know what she was trying
to protect children on youtube
how dare this how did look
she should have known better than to try
to protect the welfare of children
on youtube she should have been hunting
this is then she would have been a
[ __ ] hero then she'd have a blue
check mark instead of being a loser with
a youtube strike
don't you ever try to protect
[ __ ] children on invulnerable people
on this platform not on our watch
yeah hopefully you've learned your
lesson
[Music]
and sheila allen does look like one of
those pizzagate people
by disturbing i mean videos of kids
doing things that perverts were
commenting to each other in the comments
and being a bunch of pedos you two
fighted something about that in the past
several months but seeing as how i was
doing their job
for them i'm gonna dispute these
warnings
and probably lose and lose
[Music]
so even if the videos are not yours if
they are not on your if they are on your
playlist you will receive a strike
be careful guys here's what i tell you
man
don't don't do anything the lessons oh
no if you're gonna make edgy ass
playlists
do it do them on a burner account that's
true that's all i could tell you do it
on a burner account
that's true that's true i mean it's been
happening like i
i uh i was gonna upload a video that i
had found from
facebook it was a video somebody
recorded in a school where
it was really funny and it would have
been good for the show and it wasn't
anything crazy it was it was a uh
it was a school high school and you know
they
they it was high school where all the
kids had uniforms on whatever
and there was a fight going on right but
while they were fighting
and the fight wasn't the point in the
videos normal fight people fighting
a black kid kept break dancing while the
fight was but on the floor it was
very funny he kept like getting out of
that and then so i just uploaded it
and on one of my backup backup backup
accounts i have a [ __ ] bunch
and immediately before it even finished
processing
i got a warning on the backup account
saying you know this video shows
children in danger and you ruined
ever since that whole you know that
whole uh what was that what was that
redheaded
name well that's what we're moving
toward oh that matt watson yeah yeah
that that's what we're moving towards
we're moving towards the algorithm being
so good you're just gonna upload it's
gonna hit you immediately it's not even
yeah but
that's what happened with that video
right away
[Music]
i'm so proud of this community i'm so
proud of this game
[Music]
so that's the uh [ __ ] and that's
memeology like not that he needs our
help but you know subscribe to memeology
if you don't
uh yeah just can i just give a
shout out to uh scuff dna in the chat
sure because he just keeps repeatedly
saying guys like you know
uh you know your masters don't want you
to have knowledge and wake up and stuff
bro
thank you thank you man thanks for
thanks for being out here and getting
people woke man it's it's
it's because of it's it's a thankless
job
so and it's like being um it's like
being a firefighter or a paramedic
or a first responder it's like you're
out here
just doing god's work in youtube chats
across america
telling giving people vague marching
orders like quote
wake up and it's like without guys like
you
fighting on the front lines of the
infowar
we would be lost it's guys like you
that are keeping uh keeping the ground
in the war for america's soul uh on the
side of good and we're not giving up
ground because there's guys
like scuff dna out there telling people
don't serve the wrong masters
man wake up sheeple
and that's great because i was ready to
serve the wrong masters this morning i
woke up this morning and i'm like man
how can i serve
my masters today yeah royce comes to me
this morning goes hey
i was thinking like what if we um what
if we make a deal about
satan like make a deal with satan and
then we'll become successful and i said
are you sure dude i don't want to serve
the wrong master and then scuffy and i
the lord sent scuff dna in here
to tell us to wake up and i did i woke
up because of it i i i woke up
and i just can't again man it's just so
uh and actually scuffed his kidding but
there's so many people
that have been doing that lately have
you noticed is there an uptick on
youtube of
unironic people doing this there's an
uptick in society
everybody's just guys wake up
they're lying to you man and you're like
i know yeah we're aware
i know do you understand when i go uh
into the gas station i'm like let me get
a let me get a snickers bar and a
gatorade
how's your day going and they go i'm
doing good those people are lying to me
too man